welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only hosts
Eric Trexler but today for today's
episode I am joined by a very special
very temporary guest host named Greg
knuckles Greg thank you for joining me
thanks for having me on no problem
so if you've been listening to the
podcast we've had a little bit of a
fireside chat series going on if you
haven't listened to those they're very
off-topic episodes very laid-back
informal and not specifically about
Fitness topics per se today's episode is
going to be a normal you know fitness
focused episode so just want to make
sure everybody knows what they're
getting into today we're gonna do a lot
of QA stuff as I've mentioned previously
we are falling behind on some of those
QA submissions that we get if you're
interested in submitting one for the
future you can go to tiny CC slash SBS
QA and submit your questions there but
yeah we want to make sure you're getting
your fitness content too so that's why
today is a normal episode we do not have
feats of strength this week but we do
have a good news segment so Greg do you
want to start out with should i ah you
can take it away all right so the good
news segment the the whole idea here is
just to start out with some good vibes I
stumbled across an article on the
internet and basically the idea is I'll
put a link to the article in the show
notes here but Google arts and culture
has partnered apparently with more than
2,500 museums and galleries all around
the world and the idea is you can go to
this this website and basically tour a
variety of different you know really
cool museums all over the planet you
know high resolution images the whole
deal and I was kind of exploring it you
there's like interactive tours you can
do of these different museums and even
like like cultural sites like I was
looking around the the Colosseum in Rome
and I was looking like all over this
stuff in Italy like really cool stuff
now I'm not what you would consider a
cultured man I'm a bit of a Philistine
but even I can appreciate the fact that
this is a really cool feature like I
said
super high-resolution super immersive
experience where even from the comfort
of your own home you can explore these
different you know really cool art
galleries and museums and even some
historical sites as well so if you're
looking for for stuff to do and and that
interests you I'll put the link in the
show notes and you can go explore a
bunch of museums that you've never been
to it's pretty cool
that's awesome so from mine this is both
something that in and of itself is I
guess kind of good news good vibes and
will also helpfully hopefully help you
cultivate more good vibes for yourself
so Yael the the university puts some of
its classes online from time to time in
often like you have to pay to take them
online and it's it's cheaper than what
their normal tuition would be but they
occasionally put some up for free and so
through Coursera they recently put up
one of their courses that is
colloquially known as their happiness
course the actual course title is the
science of well-being I believe it is
their most taken online course and it is
currently open with flexible enrollment
if you want to take it for free you
can't well we'll put the link in the
description if you want to check it out
but yeah you can take it for free they
say it will take approximately 19 hours
to complete give or take in total so you
know that's something you can do to chew
up a lot of time and the whole point of
the course is to I don't know just just
help you build the skills and ability to
be more happy and productive and just
kind of chill and copacetic in general
so if those are skills you would like to
build you can take this course online
for free and the link to do so will be
in the show notes awesome so let's get
into some fitness stuff today we've got
a bunch of Q&A questions that word that
we're catching up on here why don't you
hit me with the first one you got it so
our first question is from Hakeem who
asks
do you try to limit things like caffeine
artificial sweeteners diet soda or any
calorie free things either during a diet
or a quote-unquote offseason I've been
trying to limit my overall intake of
caffeine and also trying to limit intake
of diet pop that is soda for everyone
who doesn't live in the Midwest or coke
or coke yeah where is it in the country
where they call all soda Coke I think
it's like certain parts of the southeast
ok yeah sweet oh you want to hear a fun
little fact about coke sure okay so
there's a little town in Florida and I'm
blanking on the name of the town but it
has the highest per capita concentration
of millionaires of any town in the
country and and it's just like this tiny
little rural town I'm pretty sure and
the reason why is during the Great
Depression someone noticed that like hey
most people are out of jobs like their
incomes have dried up but the one thing
that it's it still seems like everyone
is willing to spend five cents on to buy
our bottles of cold Coca Cola and so
this person had the idea that like dude
like coke seems to be recession proof at
a time when nothing seems to be
recession proof I'm going to buy as much
coke stock as I can and tell everyone
around me to buy as much coke stock as
they can and so that kind of became like
a cultural thing in this little town
it's just like if you have any money
just pour it into coca-cola stock and
that was a before coke you know exploded
and became a huge international brand
yeah and so you know there's people who
bought a couple hundred bucks worth of
coke stock and like just kept pouring
all of their money into it you know by
the 80s or 90s were all millionaires
dude I saw an interesting thing about
coke we're taking quite a tangent here I
saw an interesting thing it's got an
interesting history like like you're
indicating it's it's been a fixture in
American culture for a while now and I
saw a cool television program that was
following it was kind of a game of cat
and mouse
between coca-cola and this person that
was like way high up in the FDA but um
it was so funny because they framed it
as this like colossal showdown it was
like Al Capone and Eliot Ness like going
after each other and it's so funny
because we looked we look back at it's
something as benign as like coca-cola
tweaking their formula or whatever they
were doing but dude they were going at
it with the US government it was like a
big there's huge lawsuits it was crazy
dude those wild but anyway continue with
the question oh okay so Hakeem has been
cutting back his overall caffeine intake
sometimes it feels as though I'm
worrying about things that don't matter
too much thank you for the advice so to
circle back to the question this is the
longest question in the history of the
podcast it's been like six minutes yeah
yeah so to circle back to the actual
question Hakeem is asking is there a
point in limiting caffeine intake or
artificial sweetener and take either
while you're trying to cut or during an
offseason when maybe you're trying to
bulk yeah good question
so in general I really don't have a lot
of concerns about the popular
non-nutritive sweeteners even at pretty
liberal intake levels so if the question
is like hey should I be really conscious
about limiting those for some health or
physique related reason my general take
on it is not really you know there have
been several studies looking at a
variety of different potential
unintended consequences of high intake
of artificial sweeteners and I just
really haven't been convinced that that
they are associated with anything that's
particularly bad when it comes to actual
causative links so I know I used the
term associated there but when you
actually get down to it and look at
well-controlled studies they don't seem
to actually be causing anything that's
particularly unfavorable now I mentioned
I specifically said the popular
non-nutritive sweeteners that are
currently out there one of the things to
keep in mind when you're looking through
that literature or articles about
non-nutritive sweeteners is the one
thing that they all have in common is
that they're sweet as hell like really
really way sweeter than sugar
that's about where the similarities stop
these are very very different compounds
and so that's why you know sometimes
people will say hey I heard aspartame is
bad for this or that does that mean
sucralose is as well or stevia is as
well and unfortunately these compounds
are so different that any particular
line of research you want to follow you
really cannot assume that what's true
for one non-nutritive sweeteners gonna
be true for any other single
non-nutritive sweeteners
but in any case you know people have
looked at the research saying I'm
concerned that non-nutritive sweeteners
are gonna cause weight gain or cancer or
I mean any you know gonna cause me to
eat more subconsciously any variety of
different potential adverse unintended
consequences and the non-nutritive
sweeteners appear to be fine for
basically whatever you're looking into
so far now when it comes to caffeine
review papers on caffeine generally
advise keeping your total daily caffeine
intake under a limit of you know 400
milligrams maybe 600 milligrams a day
depending on what paper you're looking
at you know I have to be honest I don't
know where those numbers come from III
honestly think it's one of those things
where somebody just kind of picked a
number that they're like come on man why
are you going above 600 you know like
relax but I can't really find any it's
one of those those numbers like the 400
600 range it kind of just started and
then everybody says it now I'm not
actually certain how strong the evidence
for that number is but in any case if
you look at a review paper it's gonna
say 400 to 600 a days where most people
should keep the limit and Jim it's kind
of like the 220 - age max heart rate
formula exactly yeah yeah so a lot of
people don't know that but that number
was kind of just like yeah it seems to
work pretty well yeah and then everybody
went with it assuming that it was kind
of empirically derived and like a very
rigorously the determined number when in
reality was like at that seems close but
in any case yeah a lot of times you'll
see 400 to 600 in
you can argue about whether or not that
number was arrived at via robust or
rigorous methods I honestly have no idea
where it came from even though I've seen
a lot of papers use it but in any case I
do think much like the heart rate
equation it tends to be pretty all right
what I usually focus on is with your
caffeine intake if you're thinking about
limiting it the question is are you
getting jittery are you having sleep
issues are you having headaches when you
when you use too much or too little in a
given day or it has its effects just
completely worn off as far as you can
tell whenever you start to get the wrong
answer to those questions you know if
you're feeling jittery yeah you're
probably taking too much if you're
having sleep issues if you're running
into headache issues like those are some
of the tell-tale questions that can lead
you toward deciding I might be pushing
it a little bit too far with caffeine
and something that we've talked about a
lot in the past with caffeine and limits
is the fact that caffeine metabolism and
tolerance to caffeine is highly variable
between people and even within the
person depending on a variety of other
health-related habits and nutrition
related intakes so caffeine metabolism
is too complex to boil it down to like
hey everyone here's your limit but but
those are some of the things that would
make you think yeah I might want to
start limiting things but generally
speaking 400 to 600 is is probably not a
bad limit to just kind of use as your
default like null hypothesis I guess
like it'll probably work for most people
practically speaking I mean Greg I'm
sure you know several it's certainly
known in the room I'm sure you know
several people that that routinely have
like 800 or a thousand milligrams a day
I do know several people in the room who
routinely have that much caffeine and
it's like it's one of those things where
when I when I decide to start capping my
caffeine it's because the answer to some
of those questions I brought up
previously those answers are starting to
plant the idea in my head like Ed's
probably getting out of hand but
specifically the question was with
regards to dieting
so I kind of just answered in general
there but here's the thing about dieting
if you are someone like me and in the
normal offseason you're utilizing
artificially sweetened food and
beverages or you're utilizing a lot of
caffeine there's nothing wrong with that
but it does limit your ability to use
those as tools late in the diet and so
what I mean by that is a lot of times
people get late into a diet and they say
I'm gonna start consuming more caffeine
because I'm tired and I'm lethargic and
I might help with appetite a little bit
but the problem is if you're already
toward the higher end of acceptable
caffeine and takes in the offseason it's
probably gonna limit your ability to
actually utilize that and turn it into
an actionable strategy late in the diet
you've basically already utilized it in
the offseason so you can't kind of keep
it as a card that you want to play for a
little boost late in the game
and I would argue that a similar thing
can be said for artificial sweeteners
and so one of the things that I really
like to do with dieting is utilize the
easy stuff for as long as we can and so
the easy stuff would be hey you tend to
have a sweet tooth and after dinner you
like to eat something sweet what if we
swap that with something that's
artificially sweetened and boom that
that is a big calorie reduction that's
going to be sustainable day after day
and it's a nice little little trick you
can play when your diet starts to get a
little more restrictive but again if
you're if you're already using that a
lot in the offseason that there's
nothing inherently wrong with it but it
it takes those those strategies out of
the playbook when it comes to trying to
find easy ways to either mitigate
tiredness or maybe help with appetite or
maybe make some of those really easy
calorie swaps late in the diet so if
you're hoping to use caffeine or
artificial sweeteners as a crutch later
in the diet then using them very
liberally in the offseason it is going
to
impair your ability to really maximally
utilize those strategies later in the
game there's nothing wrong with it it's
just it something to keep in mind is
that if you haven't been using them in
the off season they can give you a nice
little pick me up later in the diet so
that's the only real consideration to
keep in mind when it comes to that
particular question and hopefully after
hearing that answer a lot of people are
going to go read and listen to podcasts
about the wild history of coca-cola
sounds good
alright so is this question from the
same person I think it is I didn't do
that intentionally but we may have to
Hakeem that listen to the podcast yeah
it spelled the same way though but but
anyway so a team asks I'm assigning this
to Gregg he didn't specifically asked
Gregg I don't think but the question is
how much of a difference do steroids
make for muscle growth yes so I wanted
to answer this question mostly because
several years ago maybe like three years
ago or so I wrote a steroid series for
stronger by science and I mean I don't
think any of the articles in that series
were bad but there was like an inverse
relationship between how good and useful
I thought each article was and how many
reads it got so the one that I was
personally the least jazzed about got
the most reads and the two I liked the
most were we're kind of duds so I kind
of wanted to shout those two articles
out because they're worth checking out I
believe and one thing I'll note on the
front end
neither of us use or have used steroids
so if you're looking for if you're
looking for like a practical answer to
this question of like oh hey I trained
for this long and built this much muscle
and then I ran these compounds and built
this much more muscle ask this to
another podcast so this is based purely
off of one what we have research to
support and to just what you know what
we can see from competitive bodybuilders
you know stuff that like all of us would
have access to we can just go out in the
world and look at it for ourselves
versus you know personal anecdotes about
the topic so anyway the the first
article that I wanted to mention that I
wrote several years back was called how
much more muscle can you build with
steroids so it is basically a long
answer to this exact question and so
here is the short version of the article
to answer it
first things first it's gonna be heavily
dependent on what you use in all
likelihood so you know are you talking
about you're running half a gram of test
a week and nothing else or are you
running you know like a full ifbb pro
bodybuilder stack those are both steroid
regimens and they're both very different
steroid regimens that are probably gonna
have you know very different effects on
how much muscle you can build in general
so you know we're already dealing with a
fair amount of uncertainty based on you
know what are you talking about using
but in general it appears that people
over the course of a training career can
build approximately twice as much muscle
with steroids as they would have been
able to build without steroids and so to
make it clear I'm not saying that people
who take steroids lined up with twice as
much muscle as people who don't because
that would be absurd
but in terms of like where they started
so just to put some numbers on this
we've talked about the fat free mass
index on the podcast before we're gonna
use some of those figures as reference
points it appears for untrained males
kind of an average untrained fat free
mass index number is somewhere around FF
mi of 20 and if you look at studies that
report fat free mass index for not like
competitive athletes but just kind of
day-to-day recreational lifters who've
trained for a few years it seems like
the average FF mi that you see in most
studies is somewhere around 23 give or
take and in the studies that report
you know not ifbb pro bodybuilders but
you know just again day to day lifters
who use some gear during the course of
their training you tend to see FF mi
numbers in the neighborhood of 26 so
you're seeing a gain of about 3 FF mi
points on average for just like
recreational lifters and a gain of about
6 for people who use steroids so that's
about a two-fold difference and then
kind of on the extreme end of the
spectrum so like how much how much lean
mass or fat free mass do we see the
absolute biggest drug-free people wind
up with and how much fat free mass do we
see the absolute freakiest bodybuilders
who are on gear wind up with you tend to
see fat free mass indices in the
neighborhood of 30 ish for the biggest
people without gear and fat free mass
indices in the neighborhood of 40 ish
for the biggest people with gear so
again that's that's like a 10 point game
versus about a 20 point game so again
about a two-fold difference so what I'm
trying to say here is like a two-fold
difference in terms of the amount you
gain not necessarily the amount you end
up with is a decent ballpark answer but
just to make it clear it's an incredibly
fuzzy ballpark it's gonna depend on what
you're taking how well you've respond to
gear how effective your training was
before you used gear in the first place
etc etc but yeah somewhere around the
twofold differences is a pretty decent
ballpark and so this question did ask
specifically how much of a difference do
they make for muscle growth but like I
said I want to shout out another article
that I wrote a while back and this was
the least read of the series but was my
personal favorite if you're interested
in how this relates to strength gains as
well and how much of a difference a
two-fold difference in muscle built
across a career like what that's going
to relate to in terms of how much
strength you build across a career
there's an article called the steroid
strength advantage : a theoretical
approach which is both based on you know
empirical evidence we have just
based on what tested and untested
lifters do lift and then there's also
some research on competitive power
lifters looking at what their total is
on a per kilo of fat free mass basis
because essentially the amount of muscle
you have is going to largely influence
how much weight you can lift you know
you take gear you build more muscle
that's gonna help you lift more so we
can we can model how large we would
expect the strength difference to be as
well so anyway if you're interested in
the answer on strength which is quite a
bit longer and would be probably quite a
bit more confusing to try to explain if
you can't actually look at the equations
in the article you should check it out
article again is the steroid strength
advantage a theoretical approach and
both of those articles will be linked in
the show notes good stuff alright next
question for Eric is from bin Saladin
Ben asks when experiencing strength loss
when cutting how can you tell if the
Lawson strength is a natural part of
being in a caloric deficit or a result
of overreaching this is a really good
question in a lot of people especially
if they're pushing their weight lost
pretty far and getting pretty lean a lot
of people do expect some degree of
strength loss over the course of their
cut so in many instances it makes sense
so what I'm thinking of is you know
you're an offseason bodybuilder you're
as strong as you've ever been you're
super bulked up and you're about to get
really really shredded we do expect that
in many cases there's going to be some
strength loss there and there's been a
variety of case studies and bodybuilders
that has lent support to that idea
now one thing you run into as the
question is alluding to is you know I
would contend that bodybuilders are a
bit notorious for over training or
overreaching I should say especially
during contest prep if you look at the
convergence of factors the high degree
of of cardio getting added on to
training usually people are trained in
like their life depends on it in the gym
because they
hold on to every ounce of muscle they
possibly can people are obviously under
eating you know they're in a caloric
deficit and sometimes pretty large
caloric deficit depending on their
approach so there are a lot of factors
that can contribute to overreaching
another thing is impaired sleep as you
start to get leaner as well so there's a
lot of stuff going on there and one
thing you will want to consider
throughout the course of of that type of
a weight loss phase is is it possible
that overreaching is actually clouding
my judgment of how things are going here
and so of course you could apply it to
strength like the question is asking but
another place I see this a lot is the
question of has my weight loss actually
stalled and the two questions kind of go
hand-in-hand they're both in some cases
overreaching related so a lot of times
people that are in this type of a weight
loss phase their motivation levels
through the roof they are very very
focused and in as an extension of that
they tend to be a little bit tempted to
skip D loads during their cut it's
probably a mistake
you still need D loads in that scenario
in many cases you probably need it more
than you otherwise would and so when
people reach a point where their
strength has fallen off a little bit and
their weight loss seems to be plateauing
I would argue that that's kind of a
perfect time to do a deal owed because
you can test out exactly what's
happening there I know it's admittedly
challenging to do because it goes
against your tuition if you're really
focused on a fat loss phase and you
notice that body weight is not moving
anymore and it should be based on your
daily intakes and expenditures the last
thing that you would think is you know
what I should do take my foot off the
gas pedal and just chill for a little
bit but what I what I encourage people
to do is if you're in this in this
position right and you're trying to
figure out if your lackluster strength
performance or potentially a plateau in
in in weight loss might be related to
overreaching do the D load if those
things are related to overreaching a lot
of times what I'll see with my weight
loss
clients is that we do the D load
bodyweight drops we kind of have a
flushing of kind of retained body fluid
not not a huge change in most cases but
you will see that the weight loss we
thought was happening was happening all
along we were just retaining a little
bit of fluid so in many cases you'll see
you do the D load body weight basically
corrects to where we thought it would be
there's a reduction in body weight and
we do see that performance in the gym
spikes a little bit we see that that
there was a little bit of masking of our
strength because we were just not
recovering well enough and kind of
building up some of that fatigue and
carrying it with us into the gym so in
some cases you'll see that and like I
said body weight will drop strength will
come back closer to what we expected and
that's usually a good sign that you were
overreaching a little bit and there's no
harm done that that's okay we fixed it
we did our d load we should be good to
go if you're noticing huge changes that
would mean that you were probably like
really really overreaching and then you
might consider actually saying well not
only maybe we haven't fully fixed it yet
from this D load maybe we have to really
reconsider how we want to approach this
next block of training and you know see
how long we want this D load to be but
in any case those are usually signs that
over overreaching has been the culprit
or at least a contributing factor now
let's say it goes the other way you are
you're thinking okay I think
overreaching is going on here you do the
D load bodyweight stays pretty stable
strength stays pretty stable and it
doesn't really seem to be moving so even
you know you stick with an entire d load
however long that typically is for you
and nothing seems to be moving or
budging or reacting in any way if that's
the case it might be that you are
looking at some real plateaus when it
comes to your strength performance and
also your body weight so that would be
an indicator that you might need to take
a look at the training approach the
nutrition approach and potentially
adjust course because you're clearly not
happy with how things are going there
now
if you're wondering okay well is that
normal like if it wasn't overreaching
why is my strength going down there are
a ton of different reasons why you might
notice those strength changes throughout
a cut obviously one we want to minimize
those as much as we can but to some
extent there are a lot of circumstances
where they're going to be likely those
reductions in strength performance so
things that can contribute to that one
thing is just changing leverages so if
you're losing a significant amount of
body fat like you're gonna notice that
your your squats and your deadlifts and
your bench pressing but they feel a
little bit different as the actual like
morphology of your body composition
changes so when you notice that your
your lifting belt is you know for loops
tighter I mean you're gonna feel
different when you're squatting when
there's less fat around the joints when
I mean your body is literally becoming a
different shape when you're taking on
like really big fat loss goals those
changes in leverage can be really
difficult to get used to on the fly and
so those can can certainly contribute
chronically low glycogen can be a
reality with with fat loss particularly
if you're getting pretty lean and the
deficits pretty big so chronically low
glycogen obviously is not going to be
fantastic for cultivating strength or
even maintaining strength and some in
some instances we talked about in the
past there have been some really
fascinating studies where even with you
know it's certainly not complete
glycogen depletion but even with
relatively small amounts of glycogen
depletion because of the the way those
glycogen stores are localized we can
actually see a pretty unfavorable hit
when it comes to to force and power
output of the muscle even though
glycogen is not fully depleted and so so
that's something to keep in mind we did
get very speculative when we talked a
little bit about passive tension in the
muscle due to changes in cell volume
likely a kind of an extension of the
glycogen thing very speculative it was a
fun conversation but I don't I don't
think we really have enough to go with
there yet but there were there there was
a cool study showing how changes in cell
volume can alter some of the past
of tension in the muscle wasn't that the
study where they modeled it using an
inflated condom they did yes
which fantastic methods their innovative
folks but but the the the general point
here is there are a lot of things going
on physiologically that could be
contributing to these reductions in in
your strength performance in the gym
some of them are unfortunately going to
be really hard to fully mitigate or
fully attenuate throughout the process
so as you're going throughout this fat
loss you know this phase of your
training you want to keep an eye on your
strength you want to make sure you're
still doing those d loads to try to
assess whether or not you're just
looking at poor management of your
workload or if you are actually really
losing some serious strength in the
process and if you're noticing that
strength is dropping off really
dramatically and d loads in you know
changing some of those those training
variables to make a more a more suitable
workload if those things aren't really
doing the trick and it doesn't look like
overreaching is is the culprit you might
want to consider some other aspects of
your approach that might be contributing
to those reductions in strength if I can
add something as well sure
so of the power lifters I've coached
who've tried to move down a weight class
so like obviously what I'm talking about
here wouldn't apply to someone who's you
know 12% trying to get to 6% or
something like that but pretty commonly
when people try to move down weight
classes they do get a little bit weaker
in the process and people who are really
focused on strength and performance
often have kind of a tendency to
catastrophize relatively small strength
losses so you know there's a weight that
you used to be able to do four five and
now you can just do it for three and
like oh [ __ ] it feels like the sky is
falling one of the things that helps if
you're you know primarily focused on
performance and you're trying to lose
weight is keep tabs on both how strong
you are in absolute sense but also how
strong you are in a scale
since so you know if you're competing in
powerlifting maybe you compete in a
federation that uses wilkes points maybe
you're competing in a Fed that uses IPF
points I'm personally very partial to
just allometric scaling but you know use
some sort of formula that takes both
strength and body weight into account
and if you see that your strength is
dropping off but in a way that isn't
isn't in a way that that is
disproportionate to how much body weight
you're losing such that you are losing
more body weight that then would be
expected given the strength loss then
you're still in a pretty good place so
that was a wordy way of saying if you're
losing weight your strength is going
down but your will your Wilkes points
are going up you're doing pretty well
one just in terms of the objective of
becoming a more competitive power lifter
you'll probably be more competitive in
your next meet which is good and to you
know some degree of strength loss should
be expected but if your Volks points are
still going up or maintaining stable you
know you're probably not cutting too
fast and losing too much strength even
though you may be losing a little
another thing you can do which doesn't
really is it like super helpful for for
lower body assessments but can I think
be pretty helpful for you know seeing am
i maintaining strength and performance
of the upper body pretty well is just
like from time to time do a rep max of
body weight pull-ups and dips and if you
are maintaining the number of reps you
can do that's not great but that's
pretty good if the number of reps you
can do is going up then you're probably
in a pretty good spot if you're seeing
that your body weights going down and
your maximal number of reps to failure
with bodyweight pull-ups and bodyweight
dips is also going down that then
indicates to me that you're you're
experiencing disproportionately large
strength losses so that's a pretty easy
practical test you can do to see like
you know our our these drops in strength
that I'm seeing more than less than or
about equal to what I would be expecting
yeah you
those are really good additions for sure
okay next question is from Giroux
question is I've been squatting two or
three times per week for the last year
is it reasonable to expect to continue
progressing while only squatting once a
week how should i structure it to get
the most out of it yeah sure so I think
it is perfectly reasonable to continue
making progress I think that so
frequency I think had its big moment
maybe three years ago when like super
high frequency stuff was very very chic
and people were were acting like
frequency was the main and the most
important variable for getting stronger
and I think that that people have kind
of largely settled on like yeah hey
frequency is greater than once per week
are probably good but anything beyond
like two or three times per week
probably isn't magic
but both like practical experience and
scientific evidence at this point does
point towards you know frequencies per
muscle group or per movement of two or
three times per week probably being a
little bit better than a frequency of
just once per week however that does not
then mean that you can't make progress
with a frequency of just once per week
just that you probably would make
progress a little bit faster if you did
keep your frequency a little bit higher
but you know B is slightly better than a
does not then mean that a is completely
ineffective and another thing to just
consider and think about and this is
something that you always kind of have
to keep in mind if you're looking either
a competition results or scientific data
so you know you're reading a training
study and it says like oh people did
this and they got 20% stronger and
people did this other thing and they
only got 12 percent stronger therefore
thing one is better than thing two one
thing that we don't know is whether that
purely relates to kind of like
short-term rate of progress or whether
that does act
we relate to where people will
eventually end up after years and years
of training and I kind of think that for
for some things it is going to make a
really long-term impact and for some
things it won't and so for volume for
example if you're comparing you know say
two cohorts of people training for 20
years and one of them only ever does
five sets per muscle group per week and
another does say ten or 15 I think that
after 10 or 20 years the group doing
1015 sets per muscle group per week will
probably wind up with more muscle and
more strength than the group that you
know kept volume really low the whole
time however with frequency I'm not sure
if I do actually think it matters that
much for long-term progress like I think
that it may but only a little bit but
primarily it just affects rate of
progress in the short to moderate term
and one of the reasons I think that is
like I've been around powerlifting for a
while now and I know how just training
trends have changed and developed over
time and until fairly recently pretty
low frequencies were the norm so you
know you were training each lift once a
week or maybe twice per week and the
maybe twice per week was mostly bench
press so most people would squat once
per week deadlift once per week and
benchpress twice per week or something
like that or if they train squatter
deadlift twice generally the the second
day was just kind of like a lighter like
accessory or like active recovery day so
like that that's how most people were
training you know let's say 10 years ago
give or take 10 15 years ago and so one
of the things you can do is you can pull
up open powerlifting download their data
set and look and see how lifter
performance has changed over time and I
think this is something we've talked
about on the podcast before there is
kind of the belief and understanding the
training practices have gotten better
over time and that's the reason we're
continuing to see stronger and stronger
lifters and world
kurz continue to fall whereas i think
you know world records continuing to
follow the staff unction of the sport
getting bigger and you know when you're
dealing with a larger sample size like a
larger population pool if you're looking
for outliers your odds of finding a
bigger big like a bigger and bigger
outlier gets your your odds get better
and better as just the the total sample
of competitors gets bigger and so I
think that's pretty much what's going on
because when you look at how like the
mean and standard deviation of lifter
strength changes over time it's pretty
much been the same for for as long as we
have reliable data so you know if you go
back and look and see oh how we're like
what were people lifting like what were
their Wilks points or just what were
they lifting in absolute sense in 2010
it's pretty similar to what they're
doing now like the average lifter hasn't
changed all that much the overall like
just dispersion of performance hasn't
changed all that much in terms of
standard deviations there's just you
know ten times more lifters in the sport
so we're seeing better and better people
at the very like upper class and so
relating to frequency like I was saying
before I know for sure that the average
frequency with which people train each
lift has changed over those 10 years
like I am positive of that but we don't
actually see that being reflected in
huge differences in how the average
lifter performs so yeah I do think going
back to the question which was just
asking about squat frequency I think if
you drop from a frequency of two to
three times per week to a frequency of
once per week you'll you'll probably
wind up about the same place that you
would have before you'll probably keep
making progress the progress will just
be slightly slower and in terms of how
you structure that you know that's gonna
depend on your entire training program
so it's hard to give a quick and easy
answer to that question but the one tip
I would give is you know if you're
collapsing too
three two or three squat sessions into
just one session I wouldn't necessarily
recommend taking all of that volume and
just doing it all in that one session so
you know if you were doing 15 sets
spread throughout a week
I wouldn't recommend doing 15 sets all
in one session like that's probably
gonna be absolutely ludicrous but I
would recommend overall volume for that
one squat session be higher than what
your average squat volume per session
was with a higher frequency and so you
know I I would say I would say in
general you probably wouldn't want
weekly volume to drop by more than about
50% give or take but but that's probably
a decent place to start so you know
whatever your per session volume was in
those two or three sessions per week
bump it up maybe a set or two from there
see if that's working for you see see if
that's allowing you to make progress and
if not maybe bump it up a little bit
more after that so that that's the
biggest thing I would recommend do you
have anything to add no I think you're
right it's been interesting to see you
know I first started getting into the
fitness stuff I don't know when I was
like 12 mm-hmm but even up until the age
I was like 20 it seemed like everybody
was doing what would now be considered
really low frequency stuff but but man
the last few years the hot the pendulum
kind of swung way in the other direction
and now it's like you know can I get
away with only squatting four times a
week you know it's it's been interesting
to see but no it is it's nice that we
have the kind of flexibility that we
that we enjoy right like you you can
make a lot of different training
frequencies work as long as you're
managing the other factors effectively
so no I totally agree all righty
so next question for you is from Randy
Randy asks I've heard meal timing
throughout the day is fairly
inconsequential but does the literature
show any meaningful benefits of having
higher calorie workout days and
low-calorie rest day so basically the
idea of calorie cycling and he's asking
this specifically for limiting fat
accumulation
yeah it's it's a good question you know
I'm not familiar with with any research
directly looking at that and like
specifically training days and non
training days it could be out there but
I personally haven't seen it but you
know we could certainly use similar
literature to make some some
extrapolations and some inferences from
that but I kind of prefer to just kind
of logic my way through it and to do
that you can kind of set up an even more
extreme example so if you wanted to you
could take this to an even more granular
level than just saying you know should
we manage our intake and expenditure you
know from rest days to to workout days
and kind of make sure we're matching
those things up
so the idea would be that because your
work because you're theoretically
spending less energy on off days you
should then scale your intake
accordingly to make your your 24 hour
energy balance line up better but to put
that on a 24 hour time scale as far as I
can tell is a totally arbitrary decision
so if you wanted to you could take it
even further and get more granular with
it and say why should I be eating meals
which are a large bolus of energy intake
for the for the couple hours during and
following that meal I'm in a huge energy
surplus you know what I should be doing
is just kind of spacing those bytes of
food throughout the day and making sure
that I'm keeping a more consistent
influx of energy and so you you could
make extreme examples like that and say
we could really drive ourselves crazy
trying to manage this day by day hour by
hour minute by minute you know balance
of intake and expenditure I think a much
more intuitive approach is to just let
it go to just understand that you know
there are there are temporal aspects of
nutrient timing that matter right so the
general concept of you know having at
least a bolus or a couple bolus as a day
of protein for most people I generally
recommend you know somewhere between
three to five three to six protein meals
per day
I think that's the safest bet but you
know we could certainly understand that
there is some time related aspect of
protein timing or protein intake we
don't want to have all of our protein
you know every 14th day if we go to
extremes we understand that protein
should be spaced better than that but
when it comes to energy balance when it
comes to balancing the intake and the
expenditure of just energy units we
really have to play the long game
you know micromanaging the hour by hour
day by day aspects really don't seem to
be super helpful when it comes to
limiting fat accumulation or
facilitating fat loss and when you look
at you know even some related strategies
so you might you might say well what if
we look at the alternate day fasting
literature or you know different types
of intermittent fasting where the total
caloric intake per day really changes
from day to day over the course of
several weeks of dieting did we see
really large benefits of taking that
approach not really there have been a
few really good meta analyses looking at
you know the time restricted feeding
approaches then I should say
intermittent fasting approaches that you
know for for at least a couple days out
of the week you have really low intakes
it just doesn't seem to matter that much
what really seems to matter is over the
days the weeks and the months are you
consistently in an energy surplus or an
energy deficit within those within those
guidelines obviously you want to make
sure you have sufficient protein you
want to make sure it's timed in a
reasonably sensible way I would say bare
minimum at least have a couple protein
meals per day so even if you're on a
pretty limited time window for feeding
let's say you do like let's say you do a
20 hour fast every day so your time
window for eating is only 4 hours have
protein at the beginning have protein at
the end I'd say that's probably the bare
minimum you'd want to do when it comes
to protein timing but I'm really not
super interested in managing you know
really micromanaging the day-to-day flux
of energy and the the somewhat related
literature we could lean on to try to
make inference
would suggest it's probably not that big
of a deal now there are can can I add
something in here real quick sure yeah
so I don't have the references on hand
but I think one of one of the places
where this idea got started is I've come
across a couple studies from not like a
super long time ago we're not talking
like classics from the 50s or 60s but
like I think one of the papers was from
the mid 90s and the other was from the
early 2000s but one was on track and
field athletes and the other was on
gymnasts and they were looking at like
hour by hour energy balance and body
composition yeah and they found that the
in both of these studies they found that
the athletes who were in a calorie
deficit for a larger percentage of the
hours of the day tended to have higher
body fat levels than the people who were
were closer to maintenance or at
maintenance for a larger proportion of
the hours of the day and so that I think
then spawned the idea of you know you
need to make sure that you're eating
more on training days and certainly
around training sessions so that you are
not too catabolic which then may kick in
[ __ ] starvation mode or whatever and
make you hold on to more body fat when
as you mentioned when we actually look
at longitudinal studies where you
randomized people into groups and you
can actually draw causal inferences we
see that these different patterns of
like do we fluctuate calories or do B
not doesn't really seem to matter all
that much
and so the the much more likely
explanation of those studies which I
think helped if not spawn at least blend
some degree of the appearance of
empirical support to this concept the
much more likely explanation is just
that the athletes who had higher body
fat levels were trying to diet and we're
therefore in a deficit for more hours of
the day so anyway if you were asking
this question with some of that research
in mind I think that much more likely
explanation is just yeah the of course
they were in a deficit for more hours of
the day they had more body fat they're
competitive athletes they were probably
trying to cut
versus the fact that they were in a
deficit is what made them have higher
body fat levels yeah I also wonder if
there is the possibility that there
could have been some compensatory eating
so it's like you were in a deficit for
more of the day but when you did eat you
kind of over compensated you know if
they looked into that at all I don't
remember
I haven't read either of those studies
in at least five years yeah but but but
but I do know that like so this was a
concept that I used to like completely
buy into like yeah I I went through you
know I went through a phase where I felt
like Kido was the best thing where I
thought intermittent fasting was magic
like blah blah blah like I we've talked
about this before I we both went through
kind of like extreme dietary phases as I
think most people probably have at some
point yeah but I remember like when I
was kind of on the kick of like carb
cycling and calorie cycling is super
important those were the studies that I
would see people cite a lot and I didn't
understand research methods well enough
to know that there were probably better
interpretation so like you said could be
a compensatory eating thing could be
like I was saying kind of the same thing
as like they find higher body fat
percentages in people who consume diet
coke right like yeah they're trying to
cut calories because they have higher
body fat levels so anyway just wanted to
kind of slot that in because I do still
I do still see those studies cited from
time to time yeah and also you know I
haven't seen those studies I'm I'm aware
of the concept I've heard of them but I
haven't read them myself but if they're
if they were making those assessments
based on self-reported intakes then that
opens up an entire additional can of
worms in terms of potential confounders
you know what I mean so I'm gonna go
seek those out after we record this and
take a look at those studies but the
important thing in terms of the
take-home points is that in the studies
where we do actually rigorously control
the variability of intake from day to
day like you mentioned the more rigorous
more more controlled studies with
indicate that those day-to-day
fluctuations when we look at the
longitudinal outcomes they tend to
basically get kind of washed out over
time they you know they smooth out and
what we really tend to see is the main
driving factor there is over this you
know eight week ten week whatever it is
over this period what was your overall
you know energy balance were you under
eating enough to actually induce weight
loss is really the the deciding factor
there now there are some instances where
you might consider what what I call
nonlinear Dietary Approaches so there
I'm not saying that everyone should eat
the exact same amount every single day
always there are some applications some
reasons why you might consider in doing
some fluctuations day to day the first
one is you like it that's fine it'll be
fine like there's nothing wrong with
that but in terms of like a real
targeted approach you might want to if
you're on a calorie restricted and you
know carb restricted diet you might
consider trying to sneak some carbs
closer to workouts kind of stacking them
particularly if there's a like one or
two workouts throughout the week that
you really want to make sure you've
topped off your glycogen before you head
into the gym it would make sense to put
a couple high carb days in there there's
nothing wrong with that you know we've
talked about a lot of different
potential refeed or diet break
strategies in the past the research on
diet breaks and refeeds it's kind of in
its infancy I don't think we really
fully understand exactly how efficacious
they are in the real world in practical
settings there are a few studies
indicating that they they seem to be
promising I do fear that sometimes I let
my excitement about the concept sound as
if I'm more confident in them than I
should be I do think that they're a
promising concept but but there's still
a great deal of research to be done when
it comes to figuring out do those types
of refeed and diet break strategies
actually really yield better results
over time in terms
body composition there absolutely are
studies suggesting that's the case but I
don't think it's I think we still have a
lot more to learn about whether or not
they really are when we really tightly
control for energy intake and adherence
and another thing that we have to figure
out is if these strategies do work these
diet break and refeed strategies how
long does this need to be does it need
to be a two-day refeed a three-day
refeed a two-week diet break there's a
lot that we really don't understand yet
and I think what's important is if
you're utilizing those refeed or diet
break strategies there's absolutely
nothing wrong with saying hey this is
some promising stuff and I'd like to
implement it and I think it you know
there's enough there to at least give it
a shot nothing wrong with that
whatsoever but it's really important
that as we get more research I know of
at least a few studies that should be
coming out in the next few years just
based on like pre registered trials and
stuff like that I do anticipate that we
are gonna learn a lot more about them in
the years to come which is going to be
exciting so it's really important you
know to keep an open mind about as that
literature develops really revising you
know our understanding of how we might
use some of those nonlinear dieting
strategies so working toward a summary
statement here I don't think you need to
worry about your day-to-day energy
balance I don't think you need to worry
about Oh on my off days I burned 200
less calories or 200 fewer calories so I
need to eat less on my off days I think
that's a level of micromanagement that
is not necessary and if anything might
be a net negative just based on your
sanity now if you prefer to have
nonlinear intakes just because it suits
your preferences you're not losing
anything there so there's absolutely
nothing wrong with taking that approach
now if you're going for a particular
targeted nonlinear strategy such as
stacking carbs near a particularly
important workout maybe
implementing some refeed or diet break
strategies depending on how you
structure that you could argue that
there are some benefits there so the
important thing is just kind of the the
which is that all those potential
benefits of using those nonlinear
strategies there's promising research
there but I wouldn't say that it's
conclusive research I think we still
have a lot to learn about exactly how to
structure diet breaks and refeeds and
where they may or may not actually be
effective make sense to me okay Gregg
question for you this one is from Vic
what's the latest on strength and
isometrics given gym closures and my
limited home equipment I'm thinking of
using isometrics to help maintain
strength on the squat bench and deadlift
yes so first thing I'll say of regarding
isometrics is unfortunately it may be
challenging to optimally use them if
you're like in home quarantine or your
cities under lockdown reason for that is
the ISO metrics that appear to be the
most effective are ones that you perform
them with a ballistic intent so you
tried to produce as much force as you
can as quickly as you can
and you basically exert as much force as
possible so for example if you were in a
gym and you put the safety pins at
around knee height for the deadlift and
you had a bar that was under the safety
pins and you were just trying to pick
the bar up as forcefully as possible
into the safety pins in a deadlift like
motion that would be a very effective
isometric especially if you kind of like
got the bar flush with the pins but
warnings already much force yet and then
very ballistically try to get to max
force as quickly as possible during that
isometric that is the style of isometric
that seems to be the most effective for
promoting strength gains and
unfortunately that is kind of
challenging to do if you're you know
trapped in your apartment or your house
so a very classic isometric you can do
is you can do ISO metrics with absolute
maximal force and ballistic intent in a
doorframe for your side delts you can
just have your arms down at your side
put the
back of your hands against the doorframe
and push out as hard as you as hard as
you want you know you can exert maximal
force with your side delts that way
that's great something like a squat is
gonna be a little bit more challenging
to rig up if you wanted a way to do kind
of like maximal force isometrics the
type of isometrics that people do do
sometimes where you know like let's say
you're in a push-up position and you
just hold kind of a half push-up
position isometrically it's not that
it's it's not gonna do anything that's
just not the most effective way to do
isometrics and those would probably be
most of like the isometric so you'd be
doing in in a home lockdown scenario now
something you could do is if you have a
car you could just like pull really hard
on the back bumper of a car like a
deadlift that that actually would be
pretty good so in general if it's kind
of if you're doing submaximal isometrics
where you're just holding a position
until you get tired that doesn't really
seem to be any more effective than say
you know doing push-ups through a full
range of motion for just like actual
reps and just the regular push-ups
probably would be more effective than
just the isometric push-up holds but if
you can do kind of like maximal force
ballistic intent isometrics those are
quite good and in terms of how they work
they seemed to strengthen joint ranges
of motion within about fifteen to thirty
degrees in either direction of the joint
angles that you're actually training
isometrically so you know for example if
you were doing isometric quarter squats
that's prop that's probably not gonna
really help you with strength out of the
whole whereas if you're training a squat
somewhere around your sticking point
that will probably help you get stronger
in the whole and a little bit above your
sticking point as well so yeah 15 to 30
degrees joint range of motion on either
on either direction of what's actually
being trained I think that in general
that style of isometric is at least in
theory a good
compliment to like quote-unquote normal
training because there's no eccentric
component to it so we know that it it
will help induce strength gains but it's
not going to induce nearly as much
muscle damage as like quote-unquote
normal training because there's no
eccentric component you could
theoretically do concentric only
training to get you know also benefits
without as much muscle damage and
probably make it a little bit easier to
recover from but concentric only
training is logistical II quite
challenging to set up unless unless you
have specialized equipment or a very
very understanding partner where you
know let's say you you're doing
concentric only benchpress
you benchpress the weight up you know
your your spotter takes it you take your
hands off the bar they lower it down to
your chest you push it back up again
in theory that would be great there are
actually machines that I've seen used in
research contexts before that that allow
you to do that but you know you're
probably not going to be able to do that
in most gyms so yeah I think they can be
a good complement for normal training
one of the benefits of them is that like
like I said you can train specific
ranges of motion and so it can be highly
highly specific for training weak points
so you know you're you know you're the
weakest in inch off your chest and the
benchpress you just get in a power rack
you set the pins where you know you're
pressing the bar into them when the bar
is about an inch off your chest you can
just push against those pins as hard as
you want that is training that specific
weak point in the range of motion that
is a great highly specific training and
another at least research-based benefit
of isometrics is that isometrics
performed at long muscled links seemed
to be pretty good for hypertrophy so
there was there was a meta-analysis on
this that came out I think about a year
ago which we can link in the show notes
where they basically while they looked
at a lot of different aspects of
isometrics but one of the things they
looked at is isometrics performed at
long muscled links versus short muscled
links and the impact that they have on
hypertrophy
and isometrics performed at long muscled
links seem to be pretty effective for
hypertrophy so if you were doing
isometrics to you know specifically try
to strengthen a weak range of motion in
one of the big three those weak parts of
the range of motion tend to also be at
relatively long muscle links so near the
bottom of a squat near the bottom of a
bench and so if you were doing
isometrics to train the weak points in
those lifts you're going to be putting
yourself in positions at a relatively
long muscled wing so you're probably
going to get some sort of hypertrophy
effect as well again I think it's
probably not gonna be quite as effective
for hypertrophy as like a standalone
modality as just like quote-unquote
normal training would be but as you're
doing dedicated weakpoint training there
probably will be some sort of
hypertrophic benefit as well
one thing I will say about isometrics
though is I don't feel comfortable
giving too much advice I'm just like
nitty-gritty implementation because
while there's a fair amount of research
showing that they work pretty well I
don't know that many people who actually
use them in practice and I also don't
know so it's that I don't know many
people who have ever used them often in
practice so it's not one of those things
where like science found something
coaches were like oh this seems pretty
cool let's use this with our athletes
and they found that it just didn't work
in a practical setting it's just that
like not many people do a ton of
isometrics in training period and kind
of never have um I know I've been
interested in isometrics for a while and
despite that and that interest I have
never done many I think part of that is
like they're kind of boring you know I
like picking up heavy things I like
throwing heavy iron around I know that I
can exert just as much force if not more
force into an immovable object but it's
just not as fun as throwing heavy [ __ ]
around so I don't really have that much
advice in terms of like nitty-gritty
like here's how often you should do it
here's how long each isometric should be
like here's how many total isometrics
you should do per week like I don't have
good guidelines for that I don't know of
good guidelines for that from like a
practical perspective just because I
don't know that many people who have
actually done them but if you want to
play around with isometrics like I said
there's a fair amount of research
supporting their efficacy it's something
that I'm interested in but have never
done and maybe will never do so if you
want to play around with isometrics and
report back to me with your experiences
and results I would be very interested
to hear about it
awesome I think we got time for one more
question so I want to answer this
question from Jimmy because I think it's
a really good one all right so Jimmy
asks eric has mentioned a couple times
that he's gotten down to 1,500 calories
during prep other than copious amounts
of shredded chicken what would be the
most nutritionally complete 1,500
calorie meal plant or what would the
most nutritionally complete 1,500
calorie meal plan look like yeah so this
is a good question because I think a lot
of people who unfortunately have to
consume low-calorie diets you know if
you're a smaller person or if you're
just really you know tend to be
resistant to to weight loss or you just
don't have really high activity level so
you got to really push the calories low
a lot of times people get toward the end
of a diet and they're like it's not just
that this is unpleasant but I'm
concerned that I'm not meeting my needs
as a human being like I'm just out of
stuff here at the end of the day so how
do I actually make this work and ensure
that I'm getting enough nutrients in to
actually support my health and and so
you know I've been in preps where I tend
to be very open about this I hate cardio
I don't like doing it at all and so if
for me the choice is between like kind
of starving versus like oh you can eat
more but have some cardio in there I'm
just gonna starve like a 10 times out of
10 and so I don't really mind the low
calorie thing but it is a logistic a
logistical challenge is if I'm pushing
my calories that low how do I make this
work and obviously the first part is
going to be lean proteins
horses I think that's extremely obvious
but when you're selecting your lean
protein sources something to keep in
mind is can I find some lean protein
sources that also happen to have
micronutrients in them as well and so a
variety of lean protein sources can be
utilized some of which having more more
micronutrients than others but one of
the really key things when it comes to
making these low-calorie diets work is a
diverse intake of fibrous vegetables and
so I think a lot of people will say okay
fibrous vegetables I got it but what I
would encourage people to do in this
scenario is be creative about the
variety of fibrous vegetables out there
so people think okay spinach broccoli
asparagus cauliflower and then the list
gets really short and like that those
are like the main ones that kind of jump
out for a lot of people but think of a
variety of different leafy greens that
you could go with and then think outside
the box a little bit specifically some
colorful stuff squash pumpkin beets
things like that and what you'll find is
when you mix and match your your
vegetables like I'll admit it I'm not
proud of it I used to eat pumpkin just
like plain pumpkin puree and it was a
very intuitive slide into that depraved
state that I reached so here's here's
how it started I would have oatmeal and
then I would put in pumpkin and some
Splenda and some cinnamon and it was
like a delicious pumpkin pie oatmeal
kind of thing started out innocent
enough and that was a delicious thing I
would serve that to a person with normal
food standards and they would like that
but then didn't you actually get in
trouble for making that in the office
and other people in the office with you
were like [ __ ] you Eric your foods yours
food smells too good and it's
distracting me no so what happened what
was that so this story was total BS so I
was in a I was a grad student and we
shared an office it was like 15 people
for an office the sight of light the
size of like a typical bedroom you know
I mean like there was a lot of people in
a small space and there was a microwave
and I was on a really restrict
diet and I would like this isn't good
I'll admit it I would microwave eggs in
there no no no no no but I'm getting to
a point you're talking about so I would
microwave eggs in there and people be
like dude Eric it smells disgusting when
you microwave eggs in here it's a small
room stop doing it and I should have
stopped earlier than I did I'll admit it
but eventually all right fair point so
instead I brought in oatmeal with some
some vanilla protein powder with some
cinnamon mixed in and I made my oatmeal
in the microwave put in the the powder
and the cinnamon mix it all up and
people had the nerve to get angry at me
they were mad because the egg smelled
terrible and I finally accommodated
their requests and made that and then
they were upset because it smelled too
good and everyone's like oh man I just
wish I could have that you're making me
hungry could you please stop making that
in the office at that point I said I'm
never gonna try to appease anyone ever
again
I was so annoyed by that yeah I didn't
remember the exact story but I
remembered cinnamon was in the mix
somewhere yeah the story was I finally
accommodated people and said you know
what if it makes you happy I'm happy to
do it for you and then they still didn't
appreciate it Volvo have the person who
actually got really irritated about that
who who got really annoyed with me is
like one of my very good friends so I'm
not actually angry but I will admit I
never let her live that down because I
was like you I can't believe you so
anyway it started out as a delicious
pumpkin oatmeal which actually was like
delicious and like that's a pretty solid
meal keep that in mind if you're
listening but what happened was
eventually I was like man I can't have
this many oats so the the oatmeal
serving got cut in half so it was a
little bit oats and a whole bunch of
pumpkin puree in the cinnamon and all
that stuff and it was still very good
and I don't know something happened all
of a sudden my calories were really low
and the oatmeal went from a big amount
to a small amount and then it just kind
of disappeared and eventually I was just
eating pumpkin with like a little bit of
cinnamon in it there's no Splenda I
think I actually just didn't even bother
with the Splenda because I think this is
dark
is really bad anyway is the garden a
meal so I was just eating pumpkin I I
don't know how many people listening to
this have actually just eaten pumpkin
puree cuz like when people hear pumpkin
they think pumpkin pie right yeah
they're like oh so it basically tastes
like that but like obviously it's not
quite a sweet but I think people for
whatever reason assume that pumpkin is
slightly sweet maybe because it looks
vaguely reminiscent of sweet potatoes
yeah it's not like a clean pumpkin is
disgusting well that you've gone a
little too far
play it's fine it's not good yeah so the
moral of the story is when it comes to
getting some fibrous vegetables in the
diet be creative about which ones are
going to fit because the the broader
that selection is the more likely you
are to cover your bases in terms of the
variety of vitamins and minerals that
you need in your diet another thing to
keep in mind is you know very basic
multivitamin mineral supplementation I'm
not big on taking you know huge doses of
any singular vitamin or mineral with a
few notable exceptions aside I don't
like to lean too much on a multivitamin
but this is one of those scenarios I
generally take one anyway just because
you know it's a nice little insurance
you know just say I'm sure it'll help me
cover my bases but this is another or
this is I guess a particular instance
where it makes a lot of sense to have
that insurance in place and say I'm
gonna do my best with my vegetable
intake but if I happen to come up short
then at least I can lean on that
multivitamin you you seem to be really
tickled about something over there yeah
I I wasn't I wasn't gonna butt in but
now that you've given me an invitation
anytime someone talks about
multivitamins now I cannot help but
think about the old animal pack ads so
here's here's just a fun thing to do if
you know if you're if you're cooped up
and won't some way to kill some time if
you were in the fitness industry and
let's say like 2012-2013 you undoubtedly
salt these
advertisements yeah if you're if you're
newer to the game maybe you haven't and
it's worth just googling animal PAC ad
so the thing is like supplement ads are
often just completely ridiculous
but animal pack made multivitamins like
you know it wasn't like creatine it
wasn't protein it wasn't like one of
those supplements that was purporting to
be an anabolic when it really just had
like a little horny goat weed or
whatever but like it was it was just a
straight-up multivitamin and from what I
understand it was a fine multivitamin
but it was a [ __ ] multivitamin and
like they would have all of these ads
where it was some dude who was just
unbelievably jacked he'd be like sitting
on the edge of his bed with his head
hung looking deeply depressed in like
the radiused apartment that looks like
it was in a building that was already
condemned and should have been torn down
in 1987 and like the text would be like
your life sucks no one understands you
you have no friends your family doesn't
understand what you do the iron is the
only thing that understand that
understands you at all take our
multivitamin yeah dude it's it's like so
much about the fitness space tries to be
so much more hardcore than it really is
but those animal PAC ads from like circa
2010 to 2015 really take the cake for
like trying to be dark and hardcore to a
degree that became a self parody about
multivitamins
like you should really look them up
there they're absolutely incredible the
thing is like just from the imagery
alone if you just change the captions
like it almost looks like it's like a
public service announcement it's like
listen you never know what somebody's
going through just just reach out just
be kind you know what I mean like it
looks like a person who is having the
worst moment of their entire life in an
image yeah yeah also by our multivitamin
yeah or or like or you know like it's
it's from an article about toxic
masculinity or it's just like look at
this guy like he's obviously trying to
compensate for something he's built so
much muscle to to try to be like Armour
against all of the emotional pain he's
going through like it's alright men can
cry too like yeah if you have bro
friends and they seem like they're going
through something just give them a hug
like like that looks like the kind of
image that it is but it's just like nope
your life sucks take our multivitamin
yeah I would love the idea of if you
could find someone who is unfamiliar
with the concept right and you just have
like um just have the images no text
just hold it up and be like what is this
for how many hundreds of thousands of
guesses it would take before they
thought I think that's an advertisement
for a multivitamin yeah yeah sure but
okay so like I was saying you're on very
low calories it does make sense to have
a little bit of insurance when it comes
to falling short of any particular you
know vitamin or mineral intake but I
still one of the things I fear is when
you tell tell people I'll just throw a
multivitamin and I think sometimes
people overestimate exactly how much of
a safety net that is so I always
encourage people when you're on these
low calories you still want to do your
absolute best to get the nutrients you
need from the diet itself the
supplementation is kind of the icing on
the cake it like I said it's the
insurance policy but you don't get an
insurance policy on a car and be like
sweet I'm just gonna bend this thing
around a pole you know what I mean like
treat treat it like actual insurance
which is I hope I don't need it but if I
do it's there so that that's what I'm
getting at when I say it's a good
insurance policy but still make sure
you've got a diverse intake of foods
that have abundant micronutrients in
them and then finally one thing I do
keep in the mix there when calories get
low is a fish oil supplement or
some kind of you know high quality
omega-3 supplement when your fats start
getting super low you want to have you
want to keep an eye on making sure that
you have the right fatty acids coming
into your diet when when you're bulking
and you're eating a ton of fat every day
you don't have to be quite as cautious
about it but you have to get really
efficient when it comes to making sure
that of the limited fat you're taking in
on a given day are you actually getting
decent intakes of the essential fatty
acids that your body cannot endogenous
ly produce so one of the things I often
recommend on these low caloric intakes
is you know fish oil not a bad idea
because it's a very calorically
efficient way to make sure that you're
getting some of those essential fatty
acids that you very much need so those
are the main things I do make sure your
protein sources are lean make sure
you've got a nice diverse intake of
micronutrients from the diet typically
speaking fibrous vegetables are a great
way to make that happen you can have the
insurance policy there with a nice well
formulated multivitamin and then a
little bit of fish oil on top seems to
do the trick make sense to me you want
to move on to up-and-coming creators I
think that'd be a great idea who is the
up-and-coming creator this week all
right
so standard caveat that we always put on
the segment these are people who we've
come across some of their content they
were suggested by you guys to check out
we looked over some of their stuff it
appeared to be good this does not
constitute an endorsement of everything
that anyone has ever said or all of
their opinions about all topics efforts
that is the standard caveat and with
that out of the way and so again I don't
mean that in an aggressive way like dude
the person we're shouting out they have
some good content but boy or theya piece
of [ __ ] that is very much not what we're
trying to say just that is an important
caveat to get out there it's so hard to
do because you're like how do you strike
that balance right like hey this seems
good but if there's anything that's not
good that's not what we're talking about
but we don't think there's anything
that's not good
become fine but that's where we're at
yeah so anyway for for this for this
episode it is Daniel de Brock so he is a
competitive power lifter and coach he
puts out content on a site called
stacked strength calm and most of his
content is specific to powerlifting and
strength development so he was suggested
by four or five people on our forum and
again if you want to shout someone out
or give us someone to look into you can
do that at tiny dot CC slash creators so
yeah four or five people said hey you
should check out Daniel he's putting out
good stuff
I was actually already aware of Daniel
because he submitted an article to our
website which I rejected not because it
was a bad article so one thing just to
know about us in general we we have
really high standards for guest articles
that we that we accept and so like we
turned out about 90% of them and so if
we turn down an article it's not because
it was a bad article the article he
submitted was a really good article it
was just we covered a very similar topic
on the website before so I was like ah
you know I'm gonna pass on it but you
should definitely submit this elsewhere
because it's good work so I was already
aware of Daniel and in fact to shout out
an article that he's gotten published
before he wrote an article for kabuki
strength called optimize your recovery
for maximal strength gains and it is
dare I say stronger by science esque
content if he would have submitted this
to us I would have published it in a
heartbeat it's like damn near 8,000
words very very in-depth piece on
recovery maybe the best FREE article and
just like how to recover from training
that I've come across I was aware of a
fair amount of the stuff in the article
but it is it's very impressive for its
thoroughness you should definitely check
it out it's very very good work so yeah
and the stuff he's putting out on
Instagram is high quality I just skimmed
several of the articles on his sites
stacked strength seems to be very good
content so yeah
Daniel up-and-coming creator he's
writing for a lot of different sites
seems to be you know seems to be really
making a name for himself right now
and he is someone you should check out
his site again is stack strength comm if
you want to check out his social media
we will put links to that in the show
notes and if there is someone who you
would like us to check out to
potentially get a shout out you can
submit them at tiny dot CC slash
creators alright so that just about does
it for this episode we're about out of
time but to play us out people have come
to really love our segment on cooking
tips and various ideas for people who
enjoy cooking
unfortunately that segment has been very
Greg heavy and I've got a lot of bad
feedback about that particular aspect of
it I mean my inbox is a disaster right
now so in order to accommodate some of
those messages I figured I would take
the reins and do my own cooking recipe
to play us out and Greg backed me up
this is an actual good one this one have
you looked at the recipe yeah yeah but
this one is actually good so I normally
joke around about you know for instance
just eating pure pumpkin because who
cares
but this is actually a solid recipe and
what's cool about it is the ingredients
that go into it all have insanely long
shelf life and so it's one of those
things you can just keep the stuff for
it around essentially in perpetuity and
not have to worry like it stresses me
out when I buy perishable stuff and it's
sitting in my fridge and I'm like dude I
got to make that in the next like four
days like I know how to task on my to-do
list so you can buy this stuff leave it
in the pantry for as long as you want
and it's always sitting there good to go
and it really does taste good the macros
are solid this is a really great recipe
so the recipe is for lentil soup and so
you've got lentils canned tomatoes
vegetable stock and I was at my grocery
store they have something that's just
called soup vegetables it's like in the
frozen section what was it it's like
like I said literally it's it's in the
frozen vegetable section they just
call it soup vegetables but there's like
celery a little bit of corn some cut up
like potato maybe it's just a bunch of
like high-ish fiber vegetables that
would go well in a soup
I gotcha and when they're right there
right they worked in the soup but
basically lentils canned tomatoes
basically any kind of just generic
frozen vegetable vegetable stock and so
here's the thing this makes this takes
about five minutes to make you basically
what I do is I put the lentils in canned
tomatoes I kind of just run the the
frozen vegetables under cold water to
help them get kind of thought out
quickly and just throw them in I'm
putting all this stuff in the crock pot
by the way was that assumed if I'm
talking about it it was made in a crock
pot so if you didn't fill that in
already I'm making it in a crock pot but
basically you throw that stuff in a
vegetable stock you put it in for eight
hours on low you come back at some point
later one to four days later and you got
it I'm kidding come back in time
otherwise it'll dry out you don't want
it to dry up but honestly really good
soup but here's the thing first couple
times I made it I did no spices at all
no seasonings of any kind but did you at
least add salt I did add salt okay yeah
I added salt but man the flavor was I
guess you could say bland if we're being
honest I'll admit it but the last time I
made it was actually last night I put in
onion powder cumin garlic salt and bay
leaves
what are bay leaves okay so when you
came into the house today you didn't say
what are bay leaves I'm gonna telling
you a little bit so treks comes in he's
like dude I had some lentil soup or I
made some lentil soup it was really good
I put some spices in have you heard of
cumin yeah okay yeah I mean that that
may or may not land with some people
cumin is a very common spice I was under
the impression that I had found a hidden
gem in the grocery store sure
but yeah so cumin we can go with that
pretty good but with that one our bay
leaves its I just put a leaf in there
does that really change the flavor so
Bay was added dried bay leaf or was it a
fresh bay leaf I think was dry okay so
this this is a controversial opinion I
am of the opinion that dry bay leaves
are completely inert and don't do
anything okay but if you have like some
leaves in there people are like oh they
got fancy with with how they were
flavoring this thing yeah if you go to a
store that has like fresh bay leaves you
can like you can smell them kind of like
scratch him and like sniffle that is the
flavor that they're supposed to impart
and like fresh bay leaves do add a nice
distinctive flavor to stews or stalks
yeah but I am firmly of the opinion that
dry bay leaves do literally nothing yeah
so I think I think I did a cup of
lentils one can of just diced tomatoes
one thing of frozen soup vegetables and
then 16 ounces of vegetable stock two
fluid ounces and then 16 fluid ounces of
water through a bunch of spices in there
figured out cumin is a thing also leaves
which may or may not have flavor I put
it in low eight hours honest to god it
tastes really good the macros are
fantastic and like I said it's the kind
of stuff with really long shelf life
that you buy the stuff and you know one
day you feel like soup it's all sitting
there it takes ten minutes sounds good
okay I think that does it for today's
episode in the weeks to come we are
going to have a variety of episodes
coming out some are going to be fireside
chats others are going to be more
typical on topic episodes as always
thank you for listening and we'll be
back soon
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you